hi everyone I'm Susie from the blog and
YouTube channel hell October today I'm
going to be showing you how to get super
easy beachy waves so if you want to see
my tips and tricks thank you for
watching
so I've just washed my hair and we're
gonna start off by using the wet
detangler from tangle teezer
this brush is absolutely magic it just
detangle your hair it's so easy and
effortlessly and then we're gonna be
blow-drying the hair using this fabulous
head right so I'm going to start off by
brushing my hair and brushing from the
root to the ends of my hair so now that
my hairs all dry I'm gonna be curling my
hair and I'm gonna be using the thdf
styler
I finally so so easy to use I'm gonna
section up my hair into two halves I'm
gonna start by curling the under side I
do this by taking the hair at the root
and then twisting the straighteners away
from my face and then slowly pulling
down and as you can see I'm leaving
about three centimeters of hair on the
end and with the front sections of hair
I always curl away from my face they
just find this is the most flattering
way wave your hand and once that's done
I make sure I run my hands through my
hair just to loosen up all of the curls
and this just gives it a more natural
look than brushing the cars out
sometimes you'll find you have a rogue
piece of hair that is just left uncurled
you can use your straighteners and do
half twists all the way down your hair
and it kind of makes a slightly
different wave and it just adds a more
natural look I'm just running my hands
through my hair just to loosen it up
curling your hair can be quite drying so
I like to add a little bit of oil onto
the ends just to make your hair look a
little bit more nourished so just a
couple of drops and I find this really
adds that beachy kind of sunkissed sign
to your hair I'm going to go in and add
some volume to the root of my hair and
for this I'm going to be using the
batiste dry shampoo and volume spray and
I'm just going to be spraying this into
the root of my hair so the trick with
this is not to spray it too close to
your head otherwise you're going to get
a buildup of a product and it might go a
little bit white the best way to avoid
that is to keep the
thirty centimetres away from your hair a
couple of sprays will be enough and for
my next step I'm gonna be adding at the
Toni & Guy sea salt texturizing spray
through the ends of my hair and this is
just gonna add a little bit of texture
and grit and just give you that real
beachy feel to your hair so that is the
finished look I really hope you guys
have enjoyed this please give it a like
if you did and comment down below and
for more videos like this you can check
out the glamour loop a YouTube channel
[Music]